le mr gbagbo jour en jour on parle de
cabaret neiges noires
25 ans plus tard quel souvenir
gardez-vous de cette période
c'est un moment béni le gamin dans ma
carrière et dans ma vie d'artiste la
conjonction de la pertinence de ce qui
s'est raconté c'est un jeu d'écritures
d'abord de nommer les neiges noires qui
nous tombait sur la tête
c'est une rencontre artistique avec une
gaine d'acteur c'est un grand show
d'acteurs et puis au bout de tout ça il
ya eu une rencontre miraculeuse avec le
public on la vit
moi il ya encore des gens qui m'arrêtent
sur trois panneaux dit j'ai vu cabaret
neiges on a trois fois merci merci donc
on s'acquitte un show qui fait oeuvre
utile on peut dire comme ça après
cabaret neiges noires et de l'îlot d'ici
cavernes et comment on passe au cirque
du soleil comment ça c'est passé tout ça
les gens du cirque qui était venu voir
cabaret neiges joueur qui était qu'il y
avait il y avait quelque chose là d'être
libre et délinquants et saltimbanques
même s'ils avaient pâti dans ce show là
et là il je me souviens qu'ils venaient
ils sont venus voir nos spectacles qui
est autour de l'eau d'ici tout d'un coup
qu'on soit guy laliberté dans la salle
je pense qu'il parle à l'entracte mais
il est convaincu que il ya envie de me
confier les guides d'un spectacle
finalement j'ai passé cinq ans de ma vie
aussi à faire trois shows a donné une
partie mon système nerveux jusqu'aux
hôpitaux de las vegas
dans le documentaire justement sur le
spectacle de l'homme seul que le soleil
vous signé la mise en scène une scène où
yukon où vous interpelle en vous
demandant mais aimez vous vraiment
l'oeuvre de john tenu de mon âge ça a dû
être un moment difficile à passer sinon
c'était pas un moment difficile parce
que j'avais une relation très très
soutenu avec le chrono que je
rencontrais régulièrement des critiques
et isner 6 ans yoko
allez y sont très habitués à ces les
dieux de l'olympe katia un micro-cravate
dispose sur ces personnages là que
quelques la caméra rentrent ils
connaissent le métier et yoko s'est posé
ce jour-là en protectrice de l'oeuvre de
john lennon ce qui était tout à fait
correct mais elle a joué le personnage
de yoko ono auquel on s'attendait
et stephen d intéressant elle a nommé
des choses qui sur scène marchait pas
très bien comme on peut les identifier
la halle en effet un bon spectacle parce
qu'avant kodak puis le réalisateur du
documentaire il était content d'avoir ce
moments croustillants qui à mes yeux
seulement aux yeux du coup et pas très
représentative de not making au bout de
notre relation mais qu'il a donné un bon
show vous avez trahi ipad mais contenait
yoko ono roger waters pour l'opéra de
waele quelles relations avez vous avec
toutes ces personnalités
quand je rencontre quelqu'un comme
honteuse j'ai envie de le rencontrer
réellement ça que j'ai je prends mon
courage à deux mains et fois mais
j'arrive avec des questions c'est quoi
ton rapport avec l'argent toi qui
dénonce à tout le monde en parle
la financiarisation du monde par
ailleurs tu vis au ritz collaborent à ce
système lapi charge le groupe lit quand
tu peux pour qu'on aille voir concert
n'est pas en train faire des choux
bénéfices ou des shows gratuits pour les
pauvres de l'est de montréal
écoeuré pas intéressant ben il répond
qu'il y ait plein de ses paradoxes
je pense que c'est un homme aussi à 114
en espèces de maturité j'imagine c'est
des gros ego série gens qui sont en
quelque part au dessus de la mêlée mais
par ailleurs chez waters par exemple
j'ai rencontré un orphelin qui est une
rock star riches et célèbres accompli
mais qui souffre encore du fait que
j'aie jamais connu son père qu'un
identification énorme à tous et aux
reflets que la guerre aujourd'hui est
encore en trinquet et c'est beau de voir
la rockstar riches et célèbres se tenir
debout qui revendique et comment
justement on garde ce côté créatif et
novateur un peu rebelle dans cabaret des
gens ont dit si tu veux être heureux une
heure ou une bouteille de vin si tu veux
être heureux une journée tu l'agneau
hills et festoient invite des amis
souhaitent heureux un mois fait un
voyage si tu veux être heureux un an
marie toi mais si tu veux être heureux
toute ta vie
fais-toi jardinier moi j'ai découvert le
jardin et quelques années et en collant
à la terre patiemment j'ai commencé à
jouer à l'homme qui plantait des arbres
à cultiver des salades des tomates puis
j'ai trouvé là une satisfaction dont je
pouvais pas m'imaginer l'existant
ce qui est aussi belle que c'est d'avoir
un grand soir de première mais juste un
déséquilibré c'est à dire qu'il suffit
d'un show suffit d'un acteur d'un d'un
d'une inspiration d'un engagement puis
ils vont avoir un shooter jeu fait
irruption en sortirait pas le champagne
mais remercie
[Musique]